[Applause]
Euronext
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir
newts biggest fear is working in an
office y-yeah well so what's your Bhagat
what is your greatest fear you know I've
seen Malthus and I was thinking that one
is legitimately it's a really good one
see I love offices I might be love an
office I love stationery I have a weird
obsession with stationery I never really
liked a smokeless yes escape this whole
punch so that's definitely not my fear
and ibly is deep water like really deep
water but I don't know how that would
manifest itself because it smell but
just realize I've had an epiphany mine's
probably mess yeah I I think messy a
messy room although it would have to be
a vision of my room just found that
thing in the world wants to see that
piece destroyed
let's take
shooting that scene can you walk me
through it being there what was real
what was not we've got Johnny Depp and
he's being super serious he was real
I was it was real it's all the things
that do on this film I think sometimes
people think on these beasts films that
a lot of it's done in CGI and there's a
certain built they literally built that
amphitheater and there were thousands of
supporting artists dressed as like
Wizards from all over the place what I
found amazing in that scene is Johnny is
having tonight speak this great rhetoric
intense rhetoric to this massive crowd
but he also manages to sort of charm and
sort of seduce the camera and also what
are you a fan - he's a master of I think
an efficient that he will rise to
dominance over the Wizarding World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
I also was watching the behind the
scenes and you have this shocked wing
where you literally climb out of a
suitcase yeah like I he makes it look
easy what they're amazing
is there a hole this is the true magic
again Catherine hates him when I give
away the secrets but there was one thing
that when we did the first film no
trying to work out how newt gets into
the case should there be some kind of
gravitational thing and JK Rowling was
really specific but it should be
old-school there should be steps you
should walk down so one of those and
thank you for also just doing it do you
also we do add extra steps because you
come up the ladder but then sometimes
for the camera they need a few more so
you do the real steps and then sometimes
you kind of go I can't move again
spindle fault it has to be you in your
shoes I'd probably refused to there's
late they mean it no I heard that you
went back and you watched the old Harry
Potter I mean what a great excuse sure
exactly well so what was changing I was
at work
you know it's eating popcorn and
chocolate got problems this is they are
making their tum notes that's pretty
good to me what are the greatest gifts
that you got from watching Richard
Harris and also Michael Gambon because
they're portrayals I mean everything is
very humor I think there's a humor and a
twinkle in in actually that they both
hasn't have as actors anyway but they
just bring to their most of their
performances there's a sort of yeah
sense of humor even in in in intense and
and and dire situations and a warmth
I really wanted to make sure I carried
on and in view this this sense of a good
heart
at the center of this man even despite
all his complications and his turmoil
that he's I think feeling a little more
in this film the perhaps at the age 100
and the 310 Catherine I call it the
Dumbledore twinkle wish you'd just say
in the first look he gave me that was
CGI oh can you guys have to take your
sunglasses off to Joe give it twinkles
yeah go on
there you go I just run over to over
twist it myself
magic brooms
[Music]
only in rare Souls still wings skull
from shadows no Minds simple I'm
actually terrified snooze I did a snake
in this movie so you play one and I I
was I was hearing that you had you went
and visited snakes you realized they
maybe weren't as bad as you originally
thought yes they don't attack unless
they're attacked first
they're beautiful and so soft but I'm
still horrified of Nagini and there was
this mini figurine at the studio tour I
wanted it so bad but it was so scary
looking I didn't get it but she's
halfway into this bizarre type of
aversion therapy you know what I mean
whereas this is she's essentially like
faced her fear not to her tone but the
Jews
yes I see snakes in my dreams every day
since she did the role I've had snow
snake farms and my dreams snake yeah I
don't know just a lot of things that's
the snake farm I've started for you I
didn't want to tell you about it before
but we do have the snake farm ready for
you in ever Europe we're ready to be
their king okay so there's something
that you need to get out in this course
of films there's something that there's
something that you're processing I don't
know what it is you yeah but don't we
don't we already know I mean come on
snakes
tell me snakes they're awesome and there
most sacred animistic symbols in the
living world that's true and the
Occidental faith tried to turn us
against them you know what I mean forget
that forget that noise only time the
word Occidental ever used in one of my
interviews I just want to note it okay
we're the only people you should ever
interview you're the only person you
should ever interview us and we should
only do it here wrote chiptune no we're
we're already there
all right I also heard that you didn't
know exactly we were auditioning for so
take me to that moment that you got the
script inside no no no no it was before
that so it was the scene where we were
together in London David was there I was
there to read with him and then he
dropped it and said you're a Nagini and
it's like I can't make a fool out of
myself in front of Ezra Miller myself
together have you retracted that
statement at all to impress me sometime
and this is videotape rudimental I had
to do the transformation and that went
how
okay I have to find the tape and
distraction I have some courtroom
sketches if you're watching this please
please send it back to me let's just
wrap this up by all just doing our best
snake like a shimmy I don't know it's
just what I feel like doing right now
[Laughter]
are you getting yeah there's no topic oh
my god you should have been Nikki that's
what I did Tommy disposable
nor to could mute you never met a
monster you couldn't process was toward
the big rendered the rally I mean
everything was there except for the fire
oh yeah and safety risk
how long did that take the shoot to
reach two weeks yeah was a lot everyone
started off there and then we sectioned
off yeah that's a big so when you are
not shooting that your particular shots
in such a big scene like are you still
there watching everything you do at the
beginning so you get an idea of what's
going on geography yeah I'm in your eyes
and then by the end poor Johnny the
whole job well there's a point where we
had a recording in his voice right yeah
oh yeah he gave it every time I reckon
he was behind the wall giving this
talking [ __ ] like Wizard of Oz you
know I love that like this hearing just
hearing his voice is every bit as creepy
as seeing that character I feel like
actually I mean was speaking very
quietly when he would do it which
actually made it really great but it but
sometimes hard to hear so what we have
in your life in the way that is awake
Johnny just speak out thank you sorry
right make them come to you it's
actually that's exactly what it is
I don't have to yell come to me totally
really cool choice my great speaking of
sexy answers we're calling him Dumble
[Laughter]
and he always felt it says he's finally
looks as hot as he's felt I guess he
always knew that he was hot hot so that
you even picked up though yeah name a
movie characters that you love that
you'd love to see as a young hot version
what age we talking at like 22 you tell
me plenty 9 Hagrid I really want to like
sit down for longer and explore your
Hagrid answer hi grid you know no bad
maybe just like a shape top ha hair and
like a Santa Claus like sexy Santa Claus
right I mean in this outfit Timothy
sha'lame to play Santa Claus no I'm
alive but I'm an alchemist and therefore
immortal oh you're gonna fly man Jake
was oh oh you don't look a day over 375
[Music]
in which I want to know what your
boggart is because dude has this great
moment where yakking in an office or
treats me laughs my ass yep porta
potties porta potty I deeply relate to
them yeah yeah I mean like if one showed
up in a spell like I'd be
really really unhappy about it GSA
pat-downs tragedy at the airport I feel
bad for people when I see that happening
like what are you carrying yeah
obviously this has more to do with you
yeah even worse when they're just
padding your inseam and go you're jack
black aren't you it happens really tough
and I'm like how did it wait a minute
what do you say to that I say yes yes I
am sir yes sure
but can we do subject describe to me
this so the climactic scene the big
rally is so amazing right now what's
real and what's not
did you feel uncomfortable because if
anyone knew who you really were right
besides your buddies ready I would have
been toasted I mean I don't want to
spoil anything wrong yeah we had 550
extras
or those days so it was packed and the
energy was strange how so well it felt
like you know they were there for that
the scene itself was a very secretive
scene everyone's meeting in secret you
know in the catacombs of this you know
cemetery and so that alone it's just so
freaky right yeah and just like the
people that they brought in and that
they chose everybody really dug into
this outcasts kind of people coming
together so there was a strange sort of
uneasy energy already yeah in the room
and then we had you know but then we had
Johnny speaking and you know that was
stirring the pot stirring the pot and it
was very very strange and powerful and
yes it's not a bad day at the office I
think that when you were just watching
Johnny Depp with two different colored
eyes and that glorious hair is just
making people man that stuff making
people yeah inciting them and
he's very good he's very good he's a
good bad guy you know you need a good
bad guy for a movie to work you know you
need a really and he's really good yeah
yeah yeah Johnny Depp I've heard of them
he's yeah he's a very talented boy the
only character that wasn't there
young hot Dumbledore I just want to
focus on that awkwardly for a second
okay what movie character throughout
time would you like to see as a young
hot version of themselves you know Jimmy
Stewart and it's a wonderful life Wow
wait yep well in his teens I mean not
even that much younger but just like
considering it's such an old movie you
know like I just liked it to meet like a
current age because actually the
flashbacks in that movie are so great I
second this where it's like that would
be great to see more of that yeah
crumbles those plateaus I can't help it
if you start saying that I got is no
reality Dan is it super easier to be in
a relationship when you've had your
memory erased yeah at the end of the
night just can you remember your race
and everything's fine yeah no yeah
that's a tricky exactly that's exactly I
accept I mean except I'm drew Barrymore
I like that I like that movie I'd see
that movie it's another person all
confused before later
I got a little crush on her so weird
hey are you listening drew drew I've had
a crush on you for a long time ever
since Wayne's World
I mean that's a weird example else
[Music]